[Musik]
ach wie gut dass niemand weiß dass ich
rumpelstilzchen heiß dass sich der
wahlspruch einer der berühmtesten
märchenfiguren unserer kulturgeschichte
wissensvorsprung bedeuten zuweilen
tatsächlich ziemlich viel macht aber was
heißt überhaupt etwas zu wissen
wissen sie wer ich bin und wer sie
selbst sind wo liegen die grenzen
unseres wissens und warum haben
skeptiker seit corona so schlechte
karten
ich hoffe wir finden heraus wie bei
einem heutigen gast klaus worte ist
professor für wissenschaftsphilosophie
an der universität in bern und hat
sowohl physik wie philosophie studiert
ganz herzlich willkommen danke ich freue
mich auch dass ich da bin ja kaufpreis
ab wissen sie ganz bestimmt ganz
bestimmt weiß ich dass ich hier bin dass
ich eben meinen namen gehört habe dass
zwei +24 ist aber so furchtbar viel ist
das gar nicht naja vielleicht schon mal
ein anfang und woran machen sie das fest
dass etliche dinge wissen ja dass zwei
+24 ist das kann man beweisen das folgt
aus den definitionen der zahlen das habe
ich schon oft mehr überlegt mit den
fingern nachgezählt dass ich hier bin
dass es mich überhaupt gibt das ist mir
unmittelbar gegenwärtig sofern ich bei
bewusstsein bin und ich bin bei
bewusstsein
es gibt ja verschiedene definitionen von
wissen wenn ich ihnen zuhöre denke ich
sofort wir müssen mal zuerst vielleicht
definieren was wissen überhaupt bedeutet
es gibt diese alte definition bei platin
im dialog täters wo er sagt es geht um
gerechtfertigte ware überzeugungen
genau darum geht es beim wissen und
nicht um sicherheit da steckt nicht drin
im paket
es geht zunächst um überzeugungen es
geht darum dass ich etwas für wahrheit
nehmen wir an ich weiß dass es die
dinosaurier gegeben hat dann halte ich
das erste mal war dass die überzeugung
und dann muss das auch stimmt muss
richtig sein sonst ist es ist kein
wissen
und dann kommt noch die begründung dazu
über die rechtfertigung in dem fall
könnte man sagen es gibt fossilien die
belegen ganz gut dass es diese riesen
viechern gegeben hat
das heißt also wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel nur raten wenn ich jetzt rate
wie alt sie sind und per zufall teppich
richtig dann habe ich das nicht gewusst
das würde nicht als wirkliches wissen
zellen da fehlt die rechtfertigung es
war ein zufallstreffer und gerade diese
zufallstreffer möchte man ausschließen
indem man eben rechtfertigung
begründungen belege fordert und das
gleiche stimmt ja auch wenn ich mich
irre dann ist es auch kein wissen also
wenn ich sage ich weiß dass basel die
hauptstadt der schweiz ist dann weiß ich
das nicht weil es nicht stimmt
genau das ist dann kein wissen also die
wahrheit ist auch ein teil des wissens
das merkt man sehr gut so ein
zuschreibungen andere menschen wenn ich
zum beispiel sage
gehen sie mal zu schaffen der in die
weiß wo der zug hinfährt
dann möchte ich unterstelle ich im
grunde genommen dass die schaffen
wirklich sagen kann wo der zug hingeht
und da kann ich nicht ihren da kann man
sich schon irgendwie natürlich also
wissens zu schreiben kann auch falsch
sein dass das gemeine aber wissen sie
sozusagen erstmal eine wahre meinung
oder eine war überzeugen
das heißt aber weil die und täuschen
können gibt es eine menge ex wissen also
wissen was eigentlich aber was heißt das
genau das heißt das war gar nie wissen
dinge von denen wir heute wissen dass
sie falsch waren
das war kein wissen genau genommen genau
hin und war es keinen wissen wenigstens
aus unserer perspektive war es kein
wissen also man kann sagen die wissen
hinsicht haben die menschen gewusst
das heißt sie haben fest geglaubt dass
die erde flach ist aber heute wissen wir
dass es anders ist und deshalb können
wir ihnen nicht mehr ernsthaft wissen zu
schreiben wir müssen dann sagen sie
meinten es zu wissen aber haben sich
eben darin getäuscht das ist die
qualität des wissens also man kann sich
daran enttäuschend was man eigentlich
weiß man schreibt sich dann wissen zu
man isst kann stolz auf das eigene
wissen
aber in wirklichkeit ist es kein wissen
da stellt sich dann erst im nachhinein
als irrtum heraus aber jetzt wenn ich
ihnen zuhöre habe ich den eindruck haben
wir schon zwei bedingungen für wissen
jetzt gefunden also es gibt diese
wahrheit' bedingungen das muss wahr sein
was ich weiß und was ich zu behaupten
weiß zu wissen behauptet uns zugleich
muss es eben gerechtfertigt seiner sich
muss gründe angeben können machen wir
doch mal die probe aufs exempel ich habe
ja so einen kleinen schubladen stock und
wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel hier so eine
murmel nehme ich öffne die schublade da
ist jetzt nichts drin klagte hier rein
schließe die schublade wissen jetzt wo
die wurm steckt ja in der schublade
können sie ausprobieren sie können sie
nochmal schon wäre ich ja schublade ja
an der oberen und das nehme ich das haus
so richtig und jetzt es ist wahr die
murmel ist hier das ist die erste
bedingung was ich jetzt mit der
rechtfertigung das war bei ihnen jetzt
die beobachtung also ich konnte es
tatsächlich nicht sehen als die murmeln
der schublade war aber ja ich weiß über
alltagsgegenstände die verflüchtigen
sich nicht plötzlich die lösen sich
nicht auf die fallen da nicht irgendwie
durch schubladen durch und aufgrund
dieser erfahrung habe ich dann gesagt
die murmel es weiter in der schublade
obwohl ich sie nicht mehr gesehen habe
das wäre so die begründung
und was ich hier drin das weiß ich
leider nicht wie kann ja mal reingucken
ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich viel
aber auch schauen sie mal einen
gummibaum wir haben hier ein gummiband
reingelegt aber hier ist glaube ich
tatsächlich nichts drin also das heißt
man muss vorher irgendwie eine ahnung
davon haben um dann eben gründe angeben
zu können
nun ist es aber doch so wenn man sich
das überlegt dass die wahrheit'
bedingung gar nicht so hoch gehängt wird
dann heißt das auch wir müssen nicht
wissen ob es das hier wirklich gibt ob
es murmeln an sich gibt oder ob das
alles nur ein traum ist zb sondern die
wahrheit bedingungen die ihr brauchen
wir wissen ist relativ anspruchslos
wirklich jetzt mal sagen ja obwohl wenn
ich sage ich weiß da ist die murmelt
drin ich glaube da unterstelle ich schon
dass es da eine welt außerhalb von mir
gibt indes moment gibt die nicht
unbedingt nur auf mich achten also ich
habe sozusagen gelernt dass die murmel
nicht nicht so wichtig nehmen und nicht
nur nach mir fragen und das ist die
murmeln auch gibt wenn sie so zeigen
wenn ich nicht hinschaue ich glaube
schon dass wir in ganz vielen bereichen
diese unterstellung machen das gehört
dann schon mit zur wahrheit dazu man
spricht gerne von der objektiven
wahrheit ich glaube wir machen so
abstriche bei der begründung also
beweisen kann ich halt nicht
also wenn sie mir sagen aber die mono
war gar nicht in der schublade als sie
die schublade zu war dann kann ich ihnen
das nicht beweisen
also wenn ich das hier mache und ich
sage ihnen erwarten wir wissen jetzt
nicht ob die schublade in die morgen
noch da drin ist können sie sich nicht
beweisen
ich kann es nicht beweisen
nicht ganz sicheres wissen aber es ist
schon noch wissen würde ich sagen ich
habe nicht eine ganze sieben stichfeste
begründung
ich weiß ja nicht was sie hier im sf
alles machen vielleicht ja irgendetwas
eingebaut
aber ich denke es gibt eine sehr
vernünftige vermutung und das reicht als
begründung dafür zu sagen dass es wissen
ist und wenn wir so vorgehen dann denke
ich wissen wir doch ein nicht eine ganze
menge dann wissen wir zb was passiert
ist wir wissen dass das ein tisch ist
sie wissen wie alt sie sind und woher
sie kommen und so weiter warum sagt dann
sokrates ich weiß dass ich nicht weiß
jan stecken schöne geschichte dahinter
die erzählt so hat es auch in der
apologie in seiner verteidigungsrede
und es war so dass ein freund und so hat
es eben das orakeln der hilfe gefragt
hat wer der weißeste aller menschen sei
und dann heißt des sokrates sei das und
so kann es kann das erstmal gar nicht
glauben er sagt ich weiß doch gar nicht
so viel und er macht dann die probe aufs
exempel
er geht zu anderen menschen zb zu
politikern handwerk und so weiter und
fragt die so aus was wisst ihr denn und
dabei lernt ja schon dass die einiges
wissen gerade die handwerker und
handwerkerinnen aber dass sie sich mehr
wissen anmaßen als sie eigentlich haben
sie denken eben mehr zu wissen als sie
wirklich wissen
und da sagt dazu gehört dass ich habe
eine bestimmte art von wissen dass ich
meine grenzen kenne das ich weiß wo man
wissen aufhört und das ist auch ein
wissen das die aber nicht haben und
insofern bin ich eigentlich der weißeste
also es geht um diese intellektuelle
bescheidenheit es geht nicht darum dass
wir gar nichts wissen sondern es geht
darum dass wir grenzen unseres wissens
eingestehen können gibt es aus der
wissenschaftsgeschichte ein beispiel
dafür wo man sich heillos überschätzt
habt wo wir menschen dachten gewissen
etwas und wir wussten es nicht
ja es gibt ganz viele beispiele wo
theorien die auch ganz lange für wichtig
und waage halten dann sich ein gewissen
hätten sich als falsch herausgestellt
haben also die gravitationstheorie von
newton das war eine entdeckung newton
wurde mit gott verglichen so quasi und
dann hat sich aber 200 jahre später
ungefähr ausgestellt durch ein stand das
in gewisser hinsicht die raum erfassung
und wie wir aspekte der
gravitationstheorie so nicht gestimmt
haben es gibt es dauernd ja also der weg
zum wissen ist mit irrtum gepflastert
deshalb braucht es auch diese
intellektuelle bescheidenheit
andy und sokrates mahnt und das ist
wahrscheinlich dass wichtige stichworte
oder die intellektuelle bescheidenheit
demut auch das ist eigentlich das was so
kock es uns beibringen wollte und das
ist etwas was ich eigentlich durch die
philosophiegeschichte zieht der zweifel
auch fast schon aus methode zb bei
descartes der sagt an allem ist zu
zweifeln oder auch ein bei immanuel
kants der uns daran erinnert wir sollen
selber zu denken wagen und nicht auf
autoritäten in erster linie hören also
den verstand nutzen ohne leitung eines
anderen sagt er
wenn man sich das vor augen hältst dann
denkt man doch skeptiker zu sein ist
auch die losung der stunde aber im
moment scheint gerade umgekehrt ist
attica sind gerade ein bisschen am
pranger
ja also ich finde auch erstmal die
skeptiker sind sympathische figuren auch
in der philosophiegeschichte es gibt da
so ein paar figuren die eine stelle im
unternehmen mit seinen wunderbaren
esther ist und ich mag das noch sehr
gerne und karl der antiken philosophie
ist auch skeptisch so zu sagen so eine
art von lebensführung da ist die idee
aber wir wären mit so vielen meinungen
überzeugungen beworfen heute mit dem
internet nur wir halten uns ein bisschen
raus und die seelenruhe zu finden also
in dem sinne finde ich es ist auch eine
ganz interessante einstellung gerade
heute wo jeden tag neue news über kona
kommen jetzt gibt es aber dann irgendwie
dieses phänomen von skepsis bezüglich
großer skepsis bezüglich wissenschaftler
und das haben sie angesprochen und ich
glaube da geht es eigentlich gar nicht
um diese gute alte skepsis sondern da
geht es um etwas anderes da geht es
häufig um sehr selektive skepsis sie
haben bestimmte dinge die einem nicht
ins weltbild passen eben bezweifelt und
andere dinge wären dann aber geglaubt
also die groner skeptikerin und
skeptiker die sagen ja wir brauchen
jetzt wirklich stichfeste beweise dass
das eine gefährliche krankheit ist und
die studien sind noch nicht ganz
ausgefeilt und so weiter das war ein
stück weit auch stimmen aber die eigene
überzeugung dass corona nicht so
ansteckend ist dass es gleich nicht
gefährlich ist die muss nicht weiter
begründet werden das ist dann sozusagen
denn da bestand das sind die
unterschiedlichen standards und von
daher denke ich ist manchmal auch der
ausdruck oder besser am platz als
skeptiker also ich glaube mit der guten
alten skepsis hat es nicht so viel zu
tun
sie haben vorhin gesagt man blendet dann
einfach aus was nicht ins eigene
weltbild passt das ist natürlich sehr
kritisch nun könnte man sagen na ja
woher weiß der herr weiß bad welches
weltbild eigentlich das richtige ist
ja natürlich also wir müssen immer die
gründe abwägen es gibt immer pro und
contra krönig wir sehen das ja auch
gerade in der pandemie also wir wissen
noch vieles nicht und es gibt indizien
die gegen die eine richtung es gibt
indizien in die andere richtung und die
muss man eben müssen zeigen in einer
open minded welches auf englisch also
wenn offene haltung muss man das abwägen
gegeneinander
aber es gibt halt die gefahr dass wir
uns nur das aussuchen an indizien was in
unser weltbild passt was uns bestätigt
dass dieser confirmation byers und das
ist halt gefährlich und wissenschaft
dass ein system wo man eigentlich
versucht solche verzerrungen eben
herauszuhalten und die skepsis ein stück
weit zu instrumentalisieren
bei decca tatsächlich den sie ja vorhin
genannt haben damit man dann im grunde
genommen an bei überzeugungen landete
möglichst gut begründet sind und es wird
glaube ich jetzt schon deutlich diese
skepsis drehmoment ebenso viel
diskutieren mit den in skeptikern den
corona skeptikerin vielleicht auch
crooner maßnahmen skeptikerin da werden
wir nachher noch drüber sprechen
da geht's meistens eigentlich um eine
skepsis an der wissenschaft also nicht
am wissen an sich die leute denken jetzt
nicht sie wüßten nicht mehr wer sie sind
oder sie wüssten nicht aus dass ein
tisch ist sondern es geht um eine
skepsis an der wissenschaft nun ist es
ja aber schon so dass es auch so eine
rede gibt es gibt wissenschaft gute
wissenschaft und es gibt
pseudowissenschaft das heißt man macht
diese zwei klassen in den wissenschaften
und was berechtigt uns denn dazu was
zeichnet eine gute wissenschaft aus und
was ist mit eur wissenschaft also
wissenschaft ist ein menschliches
unternehmen wo man eben versucht die
erkenntnisgewinnung auch das gewinnen
von verstehen über die welt zu
professionalisieren in unterschiedlichen
aspekten man geht planvoll vor
man versucht das wissen zu vernetzen da
etabliert sich dann so was wie ein
forschungsstand über den kann man denn
hinausgehen kann die fortschritt
erzielen und dann versucht man eben das
wissen besonders gut zu begründen und
die man systematisch nach belegen sucht
die belege systematisch abklopft im
skepsis integriert in die methode und
schauten was dann am besten begründet
ist und sollte wissenschaft abend das
immer ein stück weit nach
aber eben nicht vollständig irgendwo hab
es dann und eine möglichkeit wo es haben
kann ist das zu hypothesen aufgestellt
werden die eigentlich nicht
wissenschaftlich sind weil sie sich gar
nicht überprüfen lassen
das ist die idee der fahrbarkeit von pop
oder der überprüfbarkeit also manchmal
so ein horoskopen steht dann zum
beispiel ja wenn sie offen sind erleben
sie ein schönes eine schöne begegnung
oder sowas
aber das ist so vage was heißt das denn
offen zu sein was ist denn diese schöne
begegnung also das kann man nicht
richtig frei offizieren das kann man
nicht wissenschaftlich überprüfen und
daran scheitert es bei einigen
pseudowissenschaftlichen versuchen es
gibt dann auch andere pseudo
wissenschaften wo man vielleicht einfach
die belege und hinweise selektiv waren
nimmt dann schaut man sich nur bestimmte
evidenzen an und andere dinge werden
systematisch ausgeblendet
also das sind ebenso versuche die
bleiben irgendwo heim stecken
nun hört man so ein bisschen finde ich
den physiker in ihnen raus also was
genau heißt etwas zu überprüfen aber sie
sind ja auch philosoph ich meine eine
philosophische these kann man auch nicht
in dieser art und weise überprüfen ist
eine philosophie überhaupt wissenschaft
ja aber man kann schon mit einem
momenten um diese thesen ringe und dann
versuchen eben auf der basis der
argumente die wir haben die beste these
aus zu finden
ja philosophische fragen sind natürlich
schon schwierig und vieles kontrovers
geblieben also ich meine es gibt
philosophische fragen über die stränge
und zeitplan und sind immer noch nicht
so richtig entschieden
aber ich denke wir erzielen schon
fortschritt wir verstehen die positionen
jetzt besser wir verstehen die gründe
besser wir verstehen besser was ein
mensch vielleicht dazu bringt er ein
paar touristische position zu haben oder
eine gegenposition
ich würde trotzdem gerne noch da ein
bisschen nachhaken bei dieser frage was
genau ist jetzt solo wissenschaft und
wissenschaft jahren einige dinge jetzt
schon gesagt ich versuche mal von der
anderen seite her zu kommen wenn die
jetzt sagen moment mal aber eben eine
lex begründung können sie nicht liefern
sie können immer auch nur mit evidenzen
operieren sie können sagen dafür gibt es
bessere begründungen
aber was heißt schon besser also
vielleicht würden viele leute sagen naja
dann zeig mir doch mal was besser heißt
letzten endes immer auch die frage der
dominierenden mehrheits oder der
machtverhältnisse
das wissen wir ja auch es gibt viel
wissen was lange zeit unter verschluss
gehalten wurde was man nicht wahrhaben
wollte
weil es gewissen autoritäten nicht
gepasst hatten genau da hat der
skeptiker ja schon augen punkt auf jeden
fall also unser wissen ist manchmal von
unseren standpunkten abhängig da sagte
auch diese standpunkt theorie von donna
hay wie zum beispiel vertreten
und da gibt es ganz viele probleme also
zb hat man krankheiten häufig nur an
männer untersucht das ist auch ein
gewisser standpunkt des spiegel
vielleicht die herrschenden verhältnisse
es gibt auch so ein schönes
gedankenexperiment in der
wissenschaftsphilosophie da schickt man
unterschiedliche menschen den wald und
dann fragt man eben ja was habt ihr denn
gelernt und der biologe der entdeckter
neuen käfer und die
musikwissenschaftlerin die hört
vielleicht die vogelstimmen und der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler sieht
vielleicht wie man den wald auswerten
kann
und das sind ganz unterschiedliche
erkenntnisse ganz unterschiedliche
standpunkte ganz unterschiedliches
vorwissen geht da ein
und das denke ich muss alles zusammen
fließen das ist ganz wichtig dass wir
eben erkennen da gibt es andere
standpunkte dass wir die versuchen zu
integrieren
aber ich denke eben ist gelingt uns dann
auch diese standpunkte wirklich zu
integrieren haben gewissen zeitpunkt
also wir müssen uns mit denen
auseinandersetzen natürlich wir müssen
auch die meinungen von nicht gut
repräsentierten schichten jetzt ganz
ernst nehmen aber ich glaube wir können
uns dann sozusagen bisschen vortasten
wenn wir das alles zusammenbringen das
ist eben wissenschaft die verschiedenen
perspektiven zu integrieren um dann zu
so etwas wie einem jahr objektiven
welpen zu bekommen
sie haben erwähnt die amerikanische
wissenschaftsphilosophie spricht ja auch
vom gottes trick aber wie sagt sozusagen
die wissenschaften die dominierenden
wissenschaften würden so tun als gäbe es
sozusagen die perspektive gottes auf die
phänomene eine objektive wahrheit und
das gibt es halt nicht sondern wissen
ist immer eben sozial situiert
historisch verortet usw
jetzt haben sie so ein ganz schönes
integratives bild gezeichnet also
eigentlich müssen wir eine gruppe von
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaften in
den wald schicken und das wissen
zusammen genommen bildet dann vielleicht
das wissen ob was wir maximal kriegen
können sie selber aus physiker und
philosoph in beiden fächern promoviert
gibt es nicht den moment muss sich die
beiden perspektiven widersprechen wo sie
das gar nicht zusammenkriegen
ja das gibt es natürlich aber dann
versuche ich immer noch weiter gegeben
also das ist dann das erkenntnis zähl
ich glaube schon dass wir versuchen
müssen die perspektiven zu integrieren
natürlich gibt es da punkte wo man
wirklich an der arbeit ist also ich
meine im grenzbereich ist halt ein
kosmologie vielleicht kann man auch
darauf zu sprechen und auch
quantenphysik wo man irgendwie nicht so
richtig versteht was ist da eigentlich
los da arbeiten die philosophie ihnen
dran und die physiker und da trifft man
sich manchmal nicht so richtig aber man
muss versuchen das zusammenzubringen ich
glaube das ist der versuch erkenntnisse
zu gewinnen sonst bleibt halt jeder war
seinem eigenen standpunkt und ja dann
können wir wieder auseinander gehen
müssen sagen tschüss das war's also ich
glaube schon dass diese integration
möglich ist und wenn diese integration
möglich ist verstehe ich sofort das ist
ja auch ein demokratisches anliegen sein
könnte auch gerade in dieser krise eben
möglichst viele standpunkte zu
integrieren
wir sehen aber sehr viel mehr eine
spaltung gehässigkeiten vorwürfe
gegenseitig die kann man doch wenn
beseitigen
ja ich glaube diese gehässigkeit hat
halt viele auch zu tun mit dem neuen
mädchen und ich glaube wir müssen
einfach versuchen ins gespräch zu kommen
und im gespräch zu bleiben also zum teil
werden dann auch die kronzeugen ein
bisschen zu stark an den pranger
gestellt ich meine die wissen sich das
ist ja gut dass andere leute auch mal
andere auffassungen haben john stuart
mill hatte im 19 jahrhundert die
meinungsfreiheit verteidigt und hat
gesagt es gibt auch einen wert von
falschen überzeugungen in die falschen
überzeugungen führen dazu dass die
anderen menschen ihre meinungen
authentischer vortragen können also wenn
sie mir dauernd zustimmen wird das
gespräch und langweilig werden wenn sie
mir widersprechen da gibt es vielleicht
einen interessanten dialog und ich meine
ich glaube wir müssen zum teil noch mehr
mit den leuten sprechen und dürfen nicht
einfach nur an den pranger stellen und
was wahrscheinlich wichtig ist es möchte
ja keiner die rolle haben dessen der
zwar auch was sagen darf aber seine
meinung ist nur wichtig war es die
falsche meinung ist und weil sie mich
sozusagen voranbringen kann sondern
möchte ernst genommen werden und das ist
vielleicht wirklich diese idee vom
körper der frau sich die zier barkeit
also die einsicht wir können immer
falsch liegen und müssen deswegen auch
uns selber kritisch sehen ist
wahrscheinlich die richtige hautpflege
immer wieder am tag leben müssen
ja natürlich wir müssen uns immer fragen
haben wo stehen wir eigentlich und ich
glaube meine corona krise gibt auch
praktisch sehr viel zu diskutieren also
zum teil sind finde ich die korona
skeptikerin und skeptiker auch er ein
praktisches problem weist ein bestimmtes
verhalten an den tag legen was sie
glauben das kann man ihnen zum teil auch
schenken
jetzt haben wir darüber gesprochen
inwiefern die skepsis die wissenschaft
heute betrifft wir können aber auch
darüber sprechen warum eigentlich die
wissenschaft manchmal für menschen so
verschlossen so kalt vielleicht und
wenig verständlich daher kommt und dazu
sagt die wissenschaftshistorikerin oder
wissenschaftstheoretiker rinn eines
ramirez eine ganze menge sie aber zu
bücher geschrieben und sie sagt fakten
sind nicht das was die menschen
überzeugen sondern nur geschichten tun
darf was würde das heißen den menschen
neue geschichten zu geben
ich finde die wissenschaftsgeschichte
ist da besonders interessant weil es
gibt unheimlich spannende
entdeckungsgeschichte wie bestimmte
sachen heraus gefunden wurden und das
ist häufig so und der wissenschafts
berichterstattung da stehen dann
irgendwie nur so die fakten und ich muss
das dann einfach glauben so motto die
wissenschaftler festgestellt punkt und
ich muss das glauben dahinter stecken ja
wirklich spannende geschichten wie sind
die leute drauf gekommen
also auch wenn man zurückgeht johannes
kepler wieder gefunden hat dass die
planetenbahnen nicht kreise sind wie
sich an erhofft hatten sondern zum
beispiel ipsen
das sind ganz spannende geschichten und
da wird denke ich wissenschaft
greifbarer auch es wird greifbar ist ein
menschliches unternehmen müsse das
betont sehr sehr stark am meer ist und
das ist denke ich wirklich eine gute
möglichkeit wissenschaft zu vermitteln
aber trotzdem ist es so dass
beispielsweise verschwörungstheorien
einfach die eingänge rinn geschichten
anbieten und das ist auch eine
gefährdung für das was sie verteidigen
nämlich wissenschaft im engeren sinne ja
verschwörungstheorien sind tatsächlich
eine gefahr
verschwörungstheorien sind attraktiv
weil sie uns suggerieren ja was da
passiert ist
das ist ein langer plan und papa hat
tatsächlich gesagt das ist ein irrtum
der häufige mein tags verstand ist dass
wir irgendwie so nach geschichten suchen
wer hat das so geplant welche absicht
steht da eigentlich dahinter und
natürlich ist unser weltbild ein
stückweit kalt geworden seien sie jetzt
auch also vieles wird jetzt ja
mechanistisch erklärt in dem man eben
auf naturgesetze verweist und nicht
irgendwie auf eine absicht die dahinter
steht und das ist natürlich schon
schwierig also früher war die
wissenschaft vielleicht auch hatte eine
orientierungsfunktion dann war ein
weltweiter kosmologie oder mensch seinen
platz hatte seine aufgabe haben hat dass
das sozusagen leistet die wissenschaft
heute halt nicht mehr und dadurch werden
manchmal dann so alternative erzählungen
plötzlich attraktiv und diese frage nach
dem warum die findet man ja dann oft
auch insel sündenbock theorien dass man
auch schuldige finden wir gerade wenn
dinge passieren die überhaupt nicht
mögen die wir ganz fürchterlich finden
auch das sehen wir ja jetzt da in dieser
corona zeit wieder vielleicht ein
zweiter kritikpunkt in die korona
skeptiker skeptikerin einbringen
betrifft eben sehr viel stärker die
maßnahmen die getroffen werden und da
geht es eigentlich um einen anderen
kritikpunkt nämlich darum dass man sagt
die wissenschaft markt gut und recht
sein
aber die mischt sich zu sehr in die
politik ein und das ist eigentlich ein
vorwurf oder ein gedanke den max weber
auch schon formuliert hat er ganz klar
gesagt hat fakten an sich sind keine
politik wissenschaft sagt und wie die
welt ist aber nicht wie die welt sein
soll
da hat er doch einen punkt auf jeden
fall also ich glaube wir brauchen die
wissenschaft ganz dringend für die
bewältigung der krise an ganz vielen
punkten wir hoffen uns den impfstoff von
der wissenschaft wir hoffen uns auch die
heilung der krankheit durch die
wissenschaft und natürlich auch in der
politikberatung wir wollen dass unsere
politik fußt auf wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen
also wir wissen im moment nicht ganz
genau wie ansteckend sind die neuen
mutanten das brauchen wir
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse dazu aber
wenn die wissenschaft dann sagt ihr
müsst jetzt unbedingt einen lock down
von fünf wochen machen dann ist das
keine wissenschaftliche aussage mehr
denn so einen lock down entscheidung
beruhte auf einer abwägung es gibt
sicher die ansteckungszahlen das sind
ein wichtiger faktor aber es gibt ja
auch neben folgen haben von einem lok
dauern
boppard stark betont dass die
wissenschaft und
auch über diese nebenfolgen gelingt was
passiert jetzt in den häusern häusliche
gewalt depression usw
das muss ja auch mit berücksicht werden
und da muss man eine abwägung machen sie
eine güterabwägung da geht es eben um
werte und wertfreie wissenschaft macht
das nicht und deshalb finde ich es
tatsächlich problematisch wenn dann
manchmal so kommuniziert wird ich weiß
gar nicht ob das von der wissenschaft
intendiert ist aber so kommuniziert wird
die wissenschaft sagt die eindeutig
richtige lösung ist jetzt den noch dann
zu verlängern
das ist keine wissenschaftliche aussage
muss man ganz klar so sagen
und das muss man sozusagen abwägen und
letztlich sind es auch schritte gesagt
da sind viele interessengruppen ihm
betroffen und deshalb braucht einen
demokratischen gesellschaft daneben auch
das miteinander die diskussion und dann
schließlich politische entscheidung
das ist jetzt interessant weil sie
gesagt haben es geht um werte
entscheidungen dann sagen sie viele sind
betroffen
deswegen braucht es dem demokratischen
entscheid man könnte auch von ihnen
erwarten als widerruft was sie sagen und
das ist jetzt unser kerngebiet da sind
wir gefragt werde abwägen
güterabwägungen machen da sind die
philosophen gefragt ja das sind wir auch
gefragt auf jeden fall also in der ethik
natürlich und die ethik hilft diese
entscheidung mit zu treffen
ich würde jetzt aber trotzdem nicht
sagen lasst diese über was diese
entscheidungen einfach ein zwei
ethikerin denn letztendlich gibt es auch
in der ethik so ein imperativ der sagt
redet mit den beteiligten leute redeten
mit den betroffenen leuten
es gibt sozusagen bei solchen maßnahmen
die viele menschen betreuen betreffen
einfach auch den imperativ dass man das
gemeinsam ausmacht und dass man
strittige entscheidungen eben jetzt
nicht einfach durch expertise trifft
sondern dass man darüber redet und
deshalb ist es eindeutig eine politische
entscheidung dann ob eine maßnahme zum
beispiel der lok dann verlängert wird
oder nicht
also wenn wir jetzt das noch einmal
vielleicht wissen revue passieren lassen
habe ich den eindruck wir wissen
eigentlich doch ganz schön viel wir sind
wahr der skepsis gestartet haben jetzt
aber gesehen es gibt auch eigentlich
einiges was man rekonstruieren kann mit
diesen beiden bedingungen die wissen
eben kein zeigen wir wissen eine ganze
menge
trotzdem gibt's natürlich auch grenzen
des wissens und das betonen sie immer
wieder
man kann zum beispiel sich ein paar
grenzen leicht überlegen ich weiß zum
beispiel nicht ob sie kaviar mögen ich
weiß nicht aus welchem holz dieser tisch
hier gefertigt ist oder ich weiß zum
beispiel
auch nicht auswendig wann genau marilyn
monroe gestorben ist
das sind alles wissens grenzen sind aber
wissens grenzen die ich eigentlich
prinzipiell überschreiten könnte genau
das sind so individuell wissens grenzen
da muss man manchmal nur nachschauen im
lexikon wann ist denn gestorben oder
vielleicht kann man das mit einer
materialprobe hier genau herausfinden
aus was der tisch ist was die
philosophie besonders interessiert es
zunächst mal das menschheits wissen also
nicht das individuelle wissen sondern so
das wissen dass die wissenschaft
insgesamt eben angesammelt hat und dann
interessiert man sie in der philosophie
auch für die grenzen des wisbar rennen
also es geht darum was wir vielleicht
gar nicht wissen können
es gibt so ein schönes bild das die
wissens kugel es kann stammt von jürgen
mittels straßen und idee ist die wissens
kugel sozusagen breitet sich aus weil
wir mehr dazulernen
aber es könnte ja mal sein dass diese
kugel die expandiert plötzlich irgendwo
eine grenze stößt er geht es nicht mehr
weiter und diese grenzen des wismarer
die interessieren in der philosophie
sehr stark john bock hat darüber
nachgedacht auch natürlich kann den sie
ja vorhin schon genannt haben und über
diese wissens kugel und die grenzen
sprechen wir gleich weiter wenn ich
vielleicht noch mal ein schritt zurück
gehen also wir hatten jetzt die
individuellen wissens grenzen da kann
ich mich weiterbilden ich kann sie
befragen ob sicario mögen und so weiter
es gibt gleich noch zwei andere typen
von wissens grenzen überlege kurz
sprechen können
das eine ist die wissens grenze die zu
tun hat mit zeithorizonten also
möglicherweise wissen wir nicht genau
wie das war mit diesen pyramiden weil
uns die quellen fehlen uns natürlich
auch nicht genau was in der zukunft
passiert wir haben vermutungen können
prognosen machen aber so ganz genau
wissen wir es nicht und es gibt
qualitative grenzen des wissens ich weiß
zum beispiel nicht wie sich für sie
kopfschmerzen anfühlen ganz genau also
da gibt es auch eine schöne sache von
thomas niggl
wir wissen nicht wie es sich anfühlt
eine fledermaus zu sein eine fledermaus
hat andere organe als wir die ortet sich
selbst indem sie in auto ausstößt die
sie dann per echo wieder hört und
sozusagen orientiert sie sich im raum
und wie sich das von ihnen nahmen für
das können wir gar nicht wissen da mir
keine idee und das ist so eine art von
phänomenen ist wissen dass uns an dieser
stelle fehlt das ist prinzipiell weil
wir können nicht eine fledermaus werden
aber die wissens grenzen von der wissens
kugel die sind noch einmal an
startet ja also ich meine die wissens
grenzen können unterschiedlich zustande
kommen also manche sind eben kontingent
das ist die geschichte mit der
vergangenheit also zum beispiel wollen
wir wissen wie hat sich eigentlich das
latein oder das altägyptische angehört
aber es gibt halt keine tonträger aus
der zeit es gibt keine quellen
ja vielleicht gelingt uns aber doch
wieder irgendwie durch raffinierte
untersuchungen unserer heutigen sprachen
herauszufinden wie das latein geklungen
haben muss versucht man tatsächlich in
der linguistik
also das ist tatsächlich im einzelnen
schwer zu verhandeln aber häufig ist es
tatsächlich so dass die quellen einfach
zu sparsam sind und da gibt es dinge die
werden ja nie wissen die können wir
nicht wissen
und dann gibt es aber auch wissens
grenzen die haben wir mit naturgesetzen
zu tun
das sagen uns bestimmt und naturgesetze
über einen bestimmten bereich kommt ja
nicht raus
also wir wissen noch sozusagen das
naturgesetz dass und sagt hier ist die
grenze
aber was dann dahinter ist das können
wir nicht mehr sagen und was hat etwas
zu tun mit unserem erkenntnisvermögen
und sie verwenden selber in einem text
das bild einer greifzange also so ein
instrument hier mit dieser greifzange
kann ich zb dieses buch hier fassen
aber ich könnte zum beispiel nicht
glaube ich dass hier das hier kann ich
leider kriege ich nicht kriege ich
einfach nicht hinkriege ich nicht zu
fassen kann ich so leben wie ich will
wird nicht funktionieren so ähnlich ist
unser erkenntnisvermögen sagen sie ja
ich denke man sieht das ja schon an der
wahrnehmung also die wahrnehmung ist ein
ganz wesentliches erkenntnisvermögen
nicht das einzige war ein wichtiges und
wir können bestimmte dinge zum beispiel
nicht sehen also wir kennen uns im
bereich der festen gegenstände so
mittlerer größe zehn zentimetern 20 30
aus aber viren können wir schon mit
bloßem auge nicht mehr sehen
atome können wir nicht sehen oder auch
die weiten des universums können wir mit
bloßem auge nicht sehen und das ist
jetzt erst mal eine grenze unserer
erkenntnis da so zeigen sind unsere
erkenntnis organe eben ja zu
grobschlächtig oder nicht fein genug und
das ist eine grenze zum teil können wir
dann aber natürlich extrapolieren über
unsere wahrnehmung hinaus das ist eben
das tor
wir haben nicht nur die wahrnehmung
sondern wir können auch bestimmte dinge
erschließen und dann können wir
vielleicht erschließen
dass es da etwa die quarks gibt das wird
ja moment gemacht zum beispiel am cern
mit dem sogenannten
welchen beschleuniger da hat man
angefangen auf das mikro kleinste
elementen versuchen die sachen zu
untersuchen und zu sehen obwohl wir sie
vom bloßen auge nicht sehen können
1957 wurde im cern der erste
teilchenbeschleuniger in betrieb
genommen
hier experimentieren die forscher
seither mit den allerkleinsten teilen
und versuchen bedingungen herzustellen
wie sie beim urknall geherrscht haben
2012 konnte hier das sogenannte
higgs-teilchen nachgewiesen werden
eine antwort auf die frage warum dinge
masse haben
inzwischen ist das fern das weltgrößte
forschungslabor für teilchenphysik hier
wird in großen dimensionen gedacht
hier wird in großen dimensionen gedacht
um das allerkleinste zu sehen und haben
sie ja am anfang kurz von diesem
gespräch style jetzt über lok gesprochen
und schon lok war ja wirklich der
ansicht dass wir eben nur unseren augen
eigentlich trauen können also dass hier
kann ich noch sehen
atome kann ich nicht sehen und deswegen
weiß ich auch nichts über atome das
heißt eigentlich hat sich lok geehrt
ja genau also lok war in empirischen und
er hat sehr stark betont dass eben
unsere kenntnisse auf der
sinneswahrnehmung beruht und die ist
begrenzt und deshalb glaubte er dass
unser erkenntnis entsprechend begrenzt
ist ich denke hat zwei punkte
unterschätzt
zunächst einmal hat er unterschätzt dass
wir und sagen unsere erkenntnis werk
zurück verbessern können oder auch
verlängern können also sie haben die
greifs eingefroren gezeigt die kann ich
ja weiter entwickeln da kann ich
vielleicht da vorne noch etwas hin
brauchen nur das machen wir natürlich in
dem wir uns brillen aufsetzen
indem wir zum beispiel teleskope
benutzen mikroskope benutzen und so
weiter also in dem sein es können nur
eine magnet hat sich bei der probe
herausgefunden habe ich gedacht das ist
doch mal eine gute weiterentwicklung ja
also in diesem sinne haben wir unsere
sinnesorgane ein stückweit
weiterentwickelt und können deshalb auch
experimente mache ich mal was wir da
gesehen haben das sind ja experimente im
grunde genommen
man muss natürlich dann deuten was man
dort sieht das sind dann so interessante
bilder haben wir gesehen eben diese
teilchenspuren muss man deuten aber da
kann man experimente machen über diese
ganz kleinen teich dass der eine aspekt
und der andere aspekt ist natürlich dass
wir auch einiges
können wir können uns fragen was erklärt
eigentlich am besten was wir hier so
erleben sich der tisch erscheint mir
braun das bisschen fest und tatsächlich
hat zu beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts daneben jumper sozusagen
gesagt wir können unheimlich viel aus
unserer makroskopischen welt erklären
wenn wir diese atome annehmen also das
hat glaube ich log auch unterschätzt
dieser schluss auf die beste erklärung
dieses erschließen von neuen dimensionen
mikroskop sei es zum teil auch im
makrokosmos und das ist interessant weil
die beste erklärung was die beste
erklärung ist genau darüber wird ja dann
sehr oft gestritten und da gibt es ja
noch ein anderes wissenschafts
philosophisches prinzip nämlich orkans
rasiermesser nennt man das ein
sogenanntes sparsamkeit prinzip also
dass die beste erklärung eine ist die
möglichst gut erklären kann aber nicht
mit einer riesen geschichte
ringsum noch quasi hantieren muss was
eben verschwörungstheorien oft tun dass
sie zu viele annahmen eigentlich treffen
und geschichte viel komplizierter machen
wie sie sein könnte ja genau also häufig
spricht auch kaiser gegen solche
verschwörungstheorien aber die atom und
das ist eine relativ einfache erklärung
ist ja sogar recht anschaulich schon in
der antike gab es die aktivisten
demokrit usw
die irgendwie das vertreten habe habe
mit amazon spekulationen
damals konnte man damit nicht wirklich
viel erklären aber wenn wir jetzt
wirklich erklären kann warum zum
beispiel wasser sich ebenso verhält wie
wasser das ist gefriert bei bestimmten
temperaturen usw alles mit dieser art
hypothese dann spricht das doch dafür
für diese relativ einfache geburt jesu
ein interessantes bild der greifzange
hat meiner meinung nach immanuel kant
der ja sehr einflussreich war und viele
zuschauer und zuschauerinnen werden die
geschichte der kategorien zum beispiel
noch kennen also eine vorstellung vom
konto der these von konnte ist dass er
gesagt hat es gibt dinge die können wir
nicht erkennen sondern die legen wir
gleichermaßen in die erkenntnis mit rein
also zum beispiel den raum
ich kann zwar hier sehen es gibt kaum
raus es gibt kamera menschen es gibt
verschiedene lichtelemente es gibt also
diesen raum
aber ich kann den raum nicht sehen ich
kann nur sehen dass die dinge im raum
sind aber den raum
an sich sehe ich nicht und dass ich dann
constanze damit wissen die auch nicht ob
der raum eine grenze haben kann und ob
da etwas kommt usw
ja also das mit dem auge sein
interessante geschichte kannte ist nicht
so im touristisch orientiert wie locker
und er traut sozusagen unser verstand
unserer vernunft mehr zu und er sagt wir
bringen vielmehr mit für die erkenntnis
wir haben zum beispiel diese reine
anschauung von neben dem raum und er
meint dann aber dass wir eben über den
raum erkenntnis gewinnen können zum
beispiel der geometrie also gehen mit
rhi funktioniert hat tatsächlich gut
integriert sind auch nicht so viel
geändert könnte man sagen nicht also
winkel summe im dreieck und solche
geschichten und kann sagt ja also diesen
raum können wir erkennen aber weil es
etwa etwas ist was wir ein stück weit
eben mit bringen womit wir eben die welt
konzept realisieren dann gibt es noch
die kategorien und mit denen versuchen
wir eben auch kausalität substanz und so
weiter versuchen wir unsere erfahrung
beim zum konzept realisieren und das
gehört mit dazu und wenn wir das
berücksichtigen da müssen wir nicht so
skeptisch sein sondern können uns ein
gewisses wissen zu schreiben über die
wälder erscheinungen und trotzdem sagte
kant gewisse dinge da gibt es einfach
eine grenze es gibt diese schöne stelle
in der kritik der reinen vernunft mit
den mit den usa und den phänomenen und
er beschreibt eigentlich die welt der
phänomene der phänomenal auf seine insel
und der rest ist irgendwo im nebel das
ist die welt der nun aber können wir
nicht hin
und dazu gehörte doch auch diese frage
zb was ist eigentlich hinter dem raum
war so wo ist unser universum fertig und
was kommt danach
ja also kann ganz unterschiedliche
grenzen tatsächlich gezogen und eine
ganz wichtige grenze hat zu tun mit
unserer erkenntnis der welt im raum
es ist so eine große frage vor die wir
uns nach kant gestellt sind wie es ist
eigentlich mit der welt ist das
universum die materielle welt jetzt
unendlich im raum ausgedehnt oder geht
irgendwo mal zu ende das war so eine
große fragen wann das ist ja auch immer
diskutiert worden den philosophischen
argumenten und kann zeigt dazu
tatsächlich das könnte ja nicht wissen
er sagt sogar noch mehr dazu wenn
darüber nachdenkt wenn wir darüber mit
argumenten streiten dann verwickeln wir
uns in widersprüche
es gibt gewisse sich zwingende gründe
sagen kann zu glauben
dass die welt endlich im raum ist und
dann gibt es aber genauso zwingende
gründe zu sagen dass die welt innerhalb
des raumes unendlich sein muss dass es
da keine grenze gibt und dann haben wir
so zeigen den salat dann haben wir das
problem dass wahr zu sein so ein
wirklich eine wissens grenze und ist
ganz interessant wie das zustande kommt
bei kant kann zeigt wie erweitern und
unser wissen indem wir schlüsse ziehen
zum teil oder indem wir weitergehende
bestimmte richtung also hier ist ein
phänomen dann fragen die ja was ist denn
da neben oder was ist denn die ursache
für dieses phänomen oder was war denn
vorher und die vernunft treibt uns nach
kant weiter zu fragen
also wenn wir die erste ursache haben
dann fragt sie nach der zweiten ursache
und was ist die ursache für diese
ursache und so weiter und so fort und
kann zeigt wenn wir jetzt versuchen aufs
ganze zu gehen
die gesamtheit aller ursachen zu
erfassen oder die gesamtheit der welt
immateriellen raum dann haben wir das
problem also die wissens grenze ist
sozusagen abstrakt beschrieben kann sagt
nicht nach drei zentimetern größe hört
auf könnt ihr nichts mehr sehen oder
sowas nur sondern kann zeigt ihr könnt
nicht aufs ganze gehen ihr könnt niemals
evidenz dafür haben dass ihr alles
wissen und er beschreibt dass sie
eigentlich sogar als eine form der
verzweiflung fast schon er sagt wir
werden belästigt von fragen die uns die
vernunft auf gibt die wir aber nicht
lösen können
das ist ja so eine verzweiflung sieht ja
fast ein daraus spricht aber eigentlich
können wir jetzt sagen mit der original
relativitätstheorie haben wir das
problem gelöst wir wissen unser raum ist
endlich ja mit dem raum ist eine
schwierigkeit also tatsächlich würde ich
auch sagen irgendwas stimmt bei kant
nicht in der diskussion
ich denke hat so ein strukturproblem gut
erkannt beschrieben wir versuchen weiter
zu gehen und aufs ganze zu gehen und
dass die schwierigkeiten gibt
aber er hat das so zu sagen dann
verbunden mit einer bestimmten raum
auffassung und das hat dann tatsächlich
zu problemen geführt also tatsächlich
wird er heute in der kosmologie schon
untersucht ist darum endlich oder nicht
du da kommt man nicht in diese
widersprüche die kann so geschrieben hat
mit dem raum ist ist tatsächlich ein
problem und das ist so eine grenze die
wird eigentlich durch naturgesetze jetzt
aufgemacht
also wir wissen ja dass das universum
nur eine endliche zeit überhaupt
durchsichtig war seit dem urknall und
dann wissen wir auch dass das licht eine
ähnliche geschwindigkeit hat und das
bedeutet eben dass die lichtsignale die
jetzt hier bei uns ankommen
die haben eine lange reise hinter sich
aber sie haben nicht beliebig zeit
dort können sie nicht von beliebigen
orten kommen es gibt also orte sind
sozusagen so weit weg dass nicht von
ihnen noch nicht bei uns eingetroffen
sein kann und deshalb können wir so über
die globale geometrische struktur des
universums heute tatsächlich nicht sagen
also dieser hinsicht hat kann dort recht
allerdings nicht aus den gründen bekannt
im einzelnen gesagt hat aber ja also
damit dem raum haben wir noch ein
gewisses problem aber es ist ein anderes
problem das ist auch ganz interessant
kann wollte sozusagen die erkenntnis
grenzen apriori bestimmt er hat gesagt
ich reflektiere als philosoph ich
überlege mir wie ist das mit meiner
greifzange wie ist das mit dem
erkenntnis begriff und dann kann ich
euch sagen wo die grenzen erkenntnis
sind aber einige grenzen erkenntnis die
wir heute kennen und die besonders
signifikant sind die haben eben
naturgesetzen zu tun die wir ja
apostolow erst lernen also durch
erfahrung es ist zum teil auch
wissenschaftliche erkenntnis also die
wissenschaft hat um sich noch mehr
wissen gebracht sondern auch wissen über
wissens grenzen und diese wissens
grenzen die werden wir wahrscheinlich
gar nicht knacken können
nein also mit dieser wissens grenze
wahnsinnig schwierig weil es ist einfach
so ist wir können da keine signale von
diesem weltgegenden erhalten haben und
dann können wir nicht schließen was da
ganz genau ist ich meine es gibt schon
dem vernünftige vermutung dass dort die
naturgesetze gelten die bei uns auch
gegen quantenmechanik und so weiter aber
die galaxien am einzelnen verteilt sind
und so weiter das kann nie wissen
sie haben schon über kosmologie jetzt
gerade gesprochen und tatsächlich ist es
ein forschungsgebiet was sie auch
interessiert die kosmologie nun war ja
früher die kosmologie in der antiken
philosophie eigentlich die philosophie
das nachdenken der der wohlgeordneten
welt dass wir im gegensatz zum chaos war
der kosmos etwas geordnetes mann
versuchte diese ordnung zu verstehen
zum beispiel auch zu verstehen wer hat
diese ordnung überhaupt erst hergestellt
was macht man einen modernen kosmologie
wie sie also in gewisser hinsicht geht
man immer noch aus von der unterstellung
einer ordnung
sonst kommt man nicht weit zum beispiel
gehen wir eben davon aus dass die
gesetze der quantenmechanik auch gelten
auf anderen galaxie das ist ja gar nicht
selbstverständlich
tatsächlich hat alles gedacht dass so
zeigen im jenseits des mondes anderen
naturgesetze gelten
aber wir gehen davon aus dass die welt
ja so haben
ist das die wenigen gesetze der
quantenmechanik eben auch in fernen
galaxien gelten
warum gehen sie davon aus ja das ist so
eine vermutung ohne die vermutung würde
man wohl kaum weiterkommen aber es ist
auch so dass es natürlich bestätigt hat
als ich meine heute kann man die daten
vom hubble deep field oder so etwas
wunderbar interpretieren aufgrund dieser
annahme
also wir sind damit sehr weit gekommen
und verstehen eben ja das sind diese und
jene elemente die produzieren dann
dieses und jene nicht die sich um jene
spektrallinien usw also das hat sich ein
stück weit schon auch bewährt oder
bestätigt aber am anfang ist das
natürlich immer so eine vermutung also
papa sagt auch es ist so eine
metaphysische idee eigentlich verkäufer
nicht mal wissenschaftlich die dahinter
steckt hinter dem unternehmen und dann
suchen wir eben sozusagen nach dieser
ordnung suchen nach den naturgesetzen
aber ein stück weit bleiben ja immer
verhaftet in umfeld und das ist
irgendwie das glaube ich was nicht
ankommt immer fasziniert hat die
einsicht dass wir ein stück weit wie mit
einer inneren brille auf die dinge
schauen und die können die auch nicht
ablegen
das sieht man ja immer dann wenn man
kinder bietet irgendwie
extraterrestrisches leben zu zeichnen
dann zeigen ja immer menschen mit augen
und ohren man kann sich das schlecht
irgendwie anders denken die fantasie es
da auch beschränkt glaube ich und gibt
es nicht momente wo sich auch denken
vielleicht irgendwie uns gigantisch und
es ist alles komplett anders sie alles
was wir uns hier irgendwie ausgedacht
haben und ja also in bestimmten
bereichen ist kann schon sein dass es
sind ziemlich fundamentale irrtümer gibt
nur also gerade in der physik gibt es ja
das problem dass die relativitätstheorie
auf der einen seite mit quantenphysik
auf der anderen seite nicht zusammen
passten aber irgendwie denkt man sie
müssen zusammenpassen und jetzt gibt es
so theorie der quantengravitation die
zum teil ganz neue bilder von raum und
sein stück weit auch entwerfen natürlich
gibt es auf einer gewissen ebene raum
und zeit wie wir es erfahren aber
vielleicht ist darunter irgendwie etwas
ja das beschreiben mit kausalen gruppen
oder so etwas also das ist tatsächlich
so aber ich meine ich denke schon dass
es auch wissenschaftliches wissen gibt
dass ich jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie
umstürzen lässt durch eine neue
wissenschaftliche revolution oder so
etwas auch gerade durch die
wissenschaftlichen revolution wie wir in
der geschichte sehen gibt es ja doch
kontinuitäten natürlich wir haben vor
über gesprochen man gab es erst diese
gravitationstheorie von newton und dann
später ein stein gekommen und in
gewisser hinsicht des vieles was minuten
gesagt hat falsch und zwar ganz
konzeptionell falsch also die
wesentliche grundbegriffe sind irgendwie
problematisch aber trotzdem viel was
dann juden gesagt hat ist dann doch
irgendwie kommt wieder richtig aus wenn
man sozusagen richtig hinschaut und von
daher glaube ich schon dass vieles was
wir jetzt heute so denken ziemlich ja
ein stück weit richtig ist es kann sein
das ist irgendwie eingegossen ist in
falsche konzepte oder es kann sein dass
fundamental darunter was anderes ist
aber auch so einer gewissen ebene denke
ich schon dass da viel richtiges mit
dabei ist diesmal so war natürlich auch
die sehnsucht des menschen die
bezeichnung sie auch als homo sapiens
also aus wissende homo homini leser so
was wissen die menschen das ist uns ganz
wichtig diese neugier ist uns angeboren
das sagt auch aristoteles in der
metaphysik dass der mensch immer noch
mehr wissen drängt im moment gibt es
gerade ganz neu auf dem mars in
sogenannten navarro will der sucht
danach extraterrestrisches leben nach
irgendwelchen mikroben die da
versteinert herumliegen wenn man sowas
finden würde hätte man eigentlich den
ersten wirklichen beweis dass es eben
leben irgendwo auf dem mars gegeben hat
wieder das ihr weltbild komplett
erschüttern oder werden sie in erster
linie wahnsinnig begeistert ja also das
würde mich schon sehr interessieren sich
gehört tatsächlich eine universität bern
zum centre for space und habe die pille
da geht es um die bewohnbarkeit von
exoplaneten und das ist ganz interessant
die leute fragen dann auch wirklich
philosophen und viele so finden weil da
gibt es ein problem
wir suchen nach dem leben aber wir es
muss ja nicht unbedingt geben sein wie
es bei uns gibt es können ja andere
lebensformen geben und dann ist die
frage wonach suchen wir eigentlich an
welchen kriterien machen wir eigentlich
das leben fest
das ist die suche nach ziemlich
unbekannte und das ist ein großes
philosophisches problem das interessiert
nicht aus hängt damit zusammen was
verstehen wir eigentlich unter leben
deshalb interessiere ich mich sehr stark
für den lebens begriff und natürlich
könnte uns zb außerirdisches leben
genauer lehren was eigentlich leben
wirklich ist beim über die grenzen des
wissens sprechen dann sagen sie es ist
doch deswegen hilfreich die grenzen des
wissens zu kennen weil sie glauben das
ist eine art friedenspolitik die wir da
betreiben können es nützt nämlich
überhaupt nichts einander zu beschimpfen
oder auch nur zu streiten
über dinge bei denen wir einfach
schlicht keine antwort geben können
heißt das für sie ausmacht zum beispiel
keinen sinn über die frage gottes zu
streiten
ja also ich glaube schon dass man über
gott natürlich argumentieren kann und
aber mit dem wissens ansprüchen gerade
mit den wissenschaftlichen wissens
ansprüchen ist es halt schwierig also
gott ist sozusagen kein thema für die
empirischen wissenschaften gottes sei
ein thema für die philosophie ist eine
wissens grenze so wie wir heute wissen
schafft auffassen also wir nochmal über
erkannt reden und sagen der hat dann
auch die gottes beweisen sich angeschaut
und gesagt als beweise geht das nicht
das ist irgendwo immer fehler drin
umgekehrt gibt es auch argumente gegen
die existenz gottes aber auch da gibt es
probleme also ich denke nicht dass es da
an sozusagen den beweis für oder gegen
die existenz gottes zu den lupenreinen
gibt dabei es gibt ein sicheres wissen
natürlich auch in anderen bereichen
nicht
ja ich denke schon dass man sich
vernünftig ein stück weit darüber
unterhalten kann aber eben dann auf
einer anderen art und weise auf einer
anderen ebene und eben nicht mit
wissenschaftlichen mitteln und bei
religion geht es natürlich auch um
andere dinge es geht ja nicht nur um
irgendwie fakten neu sondern es geht ja
auch um orientierung es geht darum wie
wir uns selbst verorten es geht um
ethische dinge also von daher denke ich
ist das eine andere diskussion können
wir schon führen aber wir müssen sie
eben anders führen als die diskussion
jetzt in kona skeptikern und trotzdem
ist es interessant was zb horn tetens
ein sehr renommierter philosoph aus
berlin
der hat an eine logica sein
wissenschaftsphilosophie auch der hat es
plötzlich aufs alter hin zur
überraschung von vielen eine rationale
theologie vorgelegt und er sagt er war
auch hier schon an diesem tisch und er
sagt na ja im grunde genommen haben die
anderen eine erklärungslösung wenn sie
zeigen wollen woher eigentlich diese
ganzen naturgesetze kommen
zentis muss in ehren alles
wissenschaftlich erklären aber woher
kommen die naturgesetze und da hat er
doch eigentlich ein punkt und darüber
kann man doch schon auch wieder streiten
darüber kann man streiten ich denke mit
philosophischen mittel
es ist keine empirische wissenschaft
dann näher
aber ja ich denke darüber müssen wir uns
auseinandersetzen darüber kann man
streiten
und was da vielleicht auch dazu kommt
sind noch ganz andere formen auch
erkenntnis die sind ja selber
eine person die sehr viel musik macht
ihnen bedeutet muss ich sehr schön
spielen beim singen in einem chor
ich weiß dass sie auch sehr gerne mögen
und das kennen ja auch viele menschen
dass sie sagen wenn ich so ein bach
choral gehöre ich h moll messe von bach
dann ergreift mich dass im innersten um
in dem moment habe ich das gefühl ich
verstehe mehr und ich verstehe anderes
wie darf dass mir die wissenschaft
vermitteln kann
kennen sie dieses gefühl und was genau
verstehen wir denn da ja also der mensch
lebt nicht nur vom wissen allein machen
von diesem faktenwissen sondern in der
musik da erleben wir eine gefühle spüren
wir atmosphären stimmungen und so weiter
und das macht das leben natürlich
erstmal viel reicher nicht alles ist mit
erkenntnis ansprüchen verbunden es ist
ja auch wahnsinnig schwierig das
auszudrücken erstmal ne aber manchmal
gibt es tatsächlich momente wo man denkt
jetzt habe ich etwas erkannt wie
wunderbar doch die welt ist oder ich
habe ja ich verstehe etwas noch aber ich
glaube das ist ja auf einer anderen
ebene also wenn ich sage die welt ist
wunderbar ist ja auch keine
wissenschaftliche aussagen das ist eine
aussage auf einem jahr philosophischen
ebene wo ich mich vor ort zu der welt wo
es um meine einstellungen geht und das
erleben wir dann in einer bestimmten art
und weise und das ist auch gut dass
tritt aber nicht in konkurrenz mit der
wissenschaft war
gefährlich wirds halt wenn ich sagen
aufgrund eines solchen erlebnisses bin
ich jetzt bewohner skeptiker und weiß
ganz genau dass die impfung nicht aber
gehören diese erharts arten des
verstehens zur greifzange das ist
schwierig also ich meine wenn es um
verstehen geht dann geht es ja nicht
wirklich um wissen sondern es geht auch
um zusammenhänge
ich würde sagen wissen und verstehen ein
bisschen trennen wollen natürlich sind
bei uns auch wissenschaftliche ziele und
auch in den wissenschaften geht es um
verstehen aber verstehen es noch mal was
anderes als dieses faktenwissen und ich
denke schon die wissenschaften sollen
wir nicht so beschreiben dass es
irgendwie nur oder umgeht die fakten in
den kopf zu bekommen faktenwissen
irgendwie der haufen wächst
das ist zu einfach sondern es geht darum
ja integrierende perspektive zu
entwickeln es geht darum zusammenhänge
zu sehen
und nun ist es eben so und ich glaube
das ist das problem des grants der
grenzen auch das wissen dass eben unser
wissen auch immer unverständlich ist
aber als menschen müssen wir uns
orientieren wir müssen uns positionieren
mit vielen unserer handlungen
positionieren wir uns irgendwie wir
müssen risiken eingehen oder so etwas
sondern ist die frage wie gehen wir
eigentlich damit um was ist dann unser
selbstverständnis und auf dieser ebene
dann sind dann eben vielleicht solche
erlebnisse wichtig sind andere dinge
wichtig philosophische argumente wichtig
und das ist eine andere eben ich darf es
halt nicht mehr versuchen mit der
wissenschaft zu zeigen mit der
empirischen zu verwechseln aber dass das
auch wichtig ist würde ich nicht leugnen
wollen
jetzt haben wir über die grenzen des
wissens gesprochen über die grenzen
dessen was überhaupt erkennen und wissen
können
es gibt auch ethische grenzen des
wissens das gab es immer wieder
diskussionen darüber gibt es dinge die
wir einfach nicht wissen sollten und wo
wir die finger davon lassen sollten
denken wir beispielsweise an ein stein
der natürlich großartiges geschaffen
habt aber bei dem manchmal die frage
aufkommt wie hat sich die selber auch
gestellt wäre es besser gewesen gewisses
wissen nicht zu erlangen und nicht der
welt zu überlassen weil damit zum
beispiel auch so etwas wie die atombombe
gebaut werden konnte
ja also ich muss da denken die physiker
von friedrich dürrenmatt dieses
wunderbare theaterstück das irrenhaus
spielmann weil tatsächlich sozusagen der
physiker möbius heißt dort eben ein
wissen hat dass man zur zerstörung der
welt einsetzen kann und das
verheimlichen möchte und dann sind sie
immer die agenten hinterher von
unterschiedlichen mächten und wollen
dieses wissen so zeigen haben ja also
ich meine da gibt es ein problem ich
denke es ist nicht immer das wissen das
eigentlich so gefährlich ist die
anwendung des wissens also es ist dann
schon so dass das angewandt werden muss
und menschen müssen dann die atombombe
bauen und zünden das ist ja nochmal was
anderes als es zu wissen
aber ich meine es ist halt so dass ich
schnell anrennt findet er ist dann macht
von daher ist es vielleicht gut in
bestimmten bereichen auch ein moratorium
einzuführen und zu sagen ja wir
versuchen jetzt mal nicht weiter zu
forschen weil es einfach zu gefährlich
wird es ist aber schwierig ebenso ein
moratorium dann durchzusetzen weil man
immer die angst hat ja nie anderen die
machen es dann plötzlich und wir müssen
ja irgendwie verstehen was die anderen
machen und dann ist neugierig ja und
dann gibt es diese natürliche neugierde
von dir haben mir auch gesprochen dann
ist natürlich auch so ich meine das was
ich zum großen schaden der menschheit
einsetzen lässt kann auch zum großen
nutzen werden
wie weit man das ab das weiß man im
vorhinein auch gar nicht also ich nehme
an dass als viele grundlagen auch für zu
zeigen die forschung an atom gelegt
wurden usw hat noch nicht an die
atombombe gedacht irgendwann wohl
diesmal dann schon klar in welche
richtung das möglicherweise geht aber
die anfänge sozusagen waren im grund
genommen davon unabhängig damals nicht
gedacht dass das so was dann kommt oder
ein anderes beispiel wäre die
gentechnologie wo man heute sowohl große
hoffnungen hart schwere krankheiten
vermeiden zu können auch besser
therapieren zu können und auf der
anderen seite natürlich die angst
irgendwelche gräflichen menschen zu
schaffen von denen wir denken das sollte
auf gar keinen fall tun
es gibt aber auch wissen dass gefährlich
ist nicht für die menschheit an sich
sondern für die person die es
herausfindet ernst peter fischer hat ein
ganz wunderbares buch geschrieben mit
dem titel verbotenes wissen und er
schildert darin zum beispiel wie darwin
in einem brief gesagt hat die
evolutionstheorie die er geschaffen hat
die sozusagen vollendet hab auf ein
bisschen als würde man einen mord
geschehen weil er einfach wusste dass
ich jetzt wissen was ganz viele menschen
nicht teilen wollen und wofür er auch
ein sich selber in gefahr bringt ja also
wissen greift manchmal unser
selbstverständnis an
also manchmal wird berichtet von
erkenntnissen die angeblich zeigen dass
der mensch gar nicht frei ist also was
soll mir natürlich lieber verdrängen
ich denke man muss es dann im detail
genau diskutieren das ist wirklich so
dass diese erkenntnisse zeigen dass der
mensch nicht frei ist ich glaube es
nicht aber oder auch so zeigen
der wechsel von dem geozentrische zum
handy zentrischen weltbild galin all
diese geschichten
damals dachte man auch dieses wissen das
passende mit unserer religion zusammen
und an der religion wollte man
festhalten
heute sehen wir uns mal musste
abschwören also in dem sinne jahr kann
das wissen sozusagen extrem unpopulär
sein das kann gewisser hinsicht
gefährlich seien auch vermacht ansprüche
von bestimmten kreisen ganz klar weil
sozusagen das bisherige wissen zum teil
schon auch häufig die machtansprüche
artikuliert es ist halt ein bestimmter
standpunkt nach der standpunkt theorie
der vielleicht besonders stark geworden
ist und dann kommt ein anderer
standpunkt der muss dann auch integriert
werden aber ich meine wir schaffen das
auch diese integration also heute denken
wir zum beispiel über religion ja anders
also heute sagen wir dieser ganze streit
mit galilei das ist ja eigentlich für
die religion wichtig damals war so eine
wörtliche bibelauslegung dachte man da
gibt es bestimmte stellen ausdehnen geht
eindeutig hervor dass nach biblischem
verständnis eben sich die sonne um die
erde dreht und nicht umgekehrt nur und
dann hat man das problem aber heute
denken eben anders über diese stellen
wir interpretieren die anders und
deshalb hat sie auch unser verständnis
von religion und im zusammenspiel von
religion und wissenschaft
weiterentwickeln vielleicht zum schluss
herr weiß bad würde ich gerne noch mit
ihnen kurz über wikipedia sprechen diese
große enzyklopädie ein gigantischer
demokratisierung des wissens auch wurde
gerade eben 20 jahre alt wikipedia
weltweit umfasst mittlerweile ein wissen
was zehn mal größer ist als die größte
je gedruckte enzyklopädie wie der
heutige hatten
es gibt 300 sprachen in wikipedia als
300 verschiedene wikipedia verschiedene
sprachen in zulu in europa eher auf
schottisch zahlreiche verschiedene
nachschlagewerke wenn wir noch einmal
ihr bild nehmen der kugel heißt das dass
wir diese kugel im moment immer noch
weiter ausdehnen heißt auch dass er
tatsächlich immer mehr wissen ja also
das würde ich schon sagen man muss ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein das wissen sich
nicht einfach nur so ein haufen der
immer nur wächst manchmal wird der
haufen auch über den haufen geworfen
weil wir eben lernen dass wir uns
gewehrt haben das sind diese
wissenschaftlichen revolutionen wo man
plötzlich spürt die theorien oder die
konzept orientierung die wir besser
bisher verwendet haben die stimmen nicht
hundertprozentig das hat das beispiel
den juden neben und einstein
aber dann können wir das doch wieder
sozusagen integrieren und können dann
weiterbauen und dann wächst unser wissen
und ich meinte sieht man viele
äußerlichen indikatoren war es werden
immer mehr wissenschaftliche
zeitschriften artikel veröffentlicht und
da wächst unser wissen natürlich auf
jeden fall war früher wussten die
menschen ja wirklich ganz viel auch
auswendig die konten reihenweise
literatur rezitieren
heute denke ich reichte es eigentlich zu
wissen wo ich nachschlagen kann stimmt
das ja also das individuelle memorieren
von wissen das sollte nicht mehr so eine
große rolle spielen weil man viel
nachschlagen kann also
kann man sagen aber ich meine ich denke
wir sollten sie in der erziehung bildung
nicht unterschätzen also man muss auch
ein bisschen was wissen um zb
interessante parallelen zu sehen
es gibt in physik und in anderen
wissenschaften manchmal wirklich
überraschende parallelen zum beispiel
zwischen schwarzen löchern und
phänomenen der schallausbreitung und
flüssigkeiten denkt man erst mal das hat
auch nichts miteinander zu tun
die leute die mal drüber gearbeitet
haben ein gewisses wissen haben über die
schallausbreitung eben in diesen
flüssigkeiten die sehen plötzlich die
parallele und wenn ich jetzt sozusagen
immer nur google frage dann komme ich
nie auf diese parallele also ich denke
schon dass das wissen eine gewisse
bedeutung haben wird und insgesamt ich
habe schon gesagt ein demokratisierung
soup des wissens das sehen ja eigentlich
alle positiv tatsächlich können aber
auch alle ja mit schreiben an dieser die
pegel natürlich gibt es da auch gegen
die mechanismen und das wiederum zu
kontrollieren
sehen sie das als
wissenschaftsphilosophie durchgängig
positiv oder denken sie mama ja es war
schon auch etwas dran dass man früher
diese geld keeper hatte dass die klöster
sozusagen das listen gewütet haben und
damit auch verwaltet nein also ich denke
das wissen ein wichtiges gut ist und
möglichst viele solchen partizipieren
wenigstens an die meisten wissen
vielleicht nicht wissen wie man eine
atombombe baut oder so aber an den
meisten wissen sollten wir partizipieren
können es ist wunderbar dass das so gut
erschlossen ist auch in wikipedia ist es
ja so dass das stück weit kontrolliert
wird und das ist dann so mechanismen
gibt die dann wirklich darüber
entscheiden was dann dort steht und das
ist auch wichtig so aber ich find's toll
dass das wissen in so vielen sprachen
dann auch verfasst ist dass ich mich zb
es benutzer dann von der deutschen indie
englische geben kann oder französisch da
ist es dann doch ein bisschen anders
ausgedrückt und das ist dann eine andere
andere standpunkte noch mal spricht man
ja auch von verloren gegangenen wissen
und ich frage mich immer gibt es das
eigentlich oder ist es einfach wissen
dass obsolet geworden ist dass sich als
falsch herausgestellt hat und deswegen
memoriert man es dann nicht mehr
ja es gibt schon verlorenes wissen zb
wie die alten sprachen gesprochen wurde
das hat man damals schon gewusst das
wissen wir heute nicht mehr wahr er
keine quellen mehr haben
also so alltagswissen geschichtliches
wissen das kann schon mal vergessen
gehen oder denken sie beim vielen
kriegen wurden
die einfach die quellen zerstört meine
kirchenbücher und so weiter und dann ist
halt das wissen von oben gegangen
also in diesem sinne gibt es das schon
aber das ist natürlich wissen häufig
über einzelheiten wie wird eine
bestimmte sprache gesprochen wer wurde
wann in einem dorf geboren und dann so
etwas also so das ganz große wissen da
glaube ich nicht dass es so einfach ist
dass da etwas verloren geht
ich würde gerne noch waren sie nicht
viel mehr wissen über das wissen aber
ich weiß auch dass wir keine zeit mehr
haben ich danke ganz herzlich wie dieses
gesprächs gab sie hier waren
danke sehr ich danke sind ja nächste
woche drehen wir das thema wissen weiter
und fragen was wissen eigentlich tiere
kann eine krake denken und kann sich
eine kuh etwas merken
ich frag nach beim philosophen hanjo
glock und jetzt gleich helfen sie uns an
die fersen von dodo alias dominik judt
der gegen alle widerstände 100
popgeschichte geschrieben hat lassen sie
sich mitnehmen auf eine musikalische
abenteuerreise realisiert hat sie alexis
artery gala eine warme empfehlung für
den film und ihnen allen eine gute zeit
bis bald
[Musik]